friday american samoa recorded its first
kovit 19 case of the pandemic when a
traveler from hawaii tested positive
this takes american samoa off a
dwindling list of countries that have
managed to avoid the respiratory disease
since the pandemic began what do those
countries that have managed to avoid
kobet have in common the vast majority
of the places that have kept covet 19
out are other island nations and
territories
the cook islands nauru
nue
tokulau saint helena the federated
states of micronesia tonga tuvalu the
pitcairn islands and kiribati have all
avoided the disease according to the
world health organization
many of these islands have been helped
by strict covet 19 protocols that have
restricted outside travelers as well as
being small islands with relatively few
visitors and small populations the
largest countries that haven't reported
any covet 19 cases to the who are north
korea and turkmenistan though both of
those countries are suspected to have
had kovid 19 cases that have gone
unreported but besides intentional
government interference there are other
reasons countries may not have reported
covet cases while it's possible these
countries haven't detected any cases
because there haven't been any covet 19
infections it's also possible some cases
could have gone unreported due to
inadequate testing or virus spread that
went undetected
according to american samoa's department
of homeland security the infected person
was a fully vaccinated traveler who
tested positive while quarantining after
arriving on the island officials report
the traveler was asymptomatic
american samoa governor lamanu mauga who
the associated press reports was on the
same flight as the covet infected
traveler and is now in quarantine said
in a statement the positive case proved
why the country's coveted mitigation
protocols have been effective saying it
highlights quote the importance of
maintaining our current quarantine
protocols for comparison as of september
23rd the united states recorded the most
coveted 19 infections with more than 42
million cases
india and brazil have the second and
third highest case counts with more than
33.5 and 21.2 million cases respectively